- I just want people to
prove their love for me.
We met in December.
We've been dating five months.
- It's been about a year.
- We've been dating for
two and a half years.
- We met working at BuzzFeed
- My friend TA'd her class and I was like,
"Yo, who's the blonde?"
- We joined a gay bowling league,
- [Woman] Which I am also.
(laughs)
- We've known each other two years?
- Two years.
- But it feels like a life time.
- We've known each for about a year.
- Almost four years.
- I thought we'd went to
camp together but we hadn't.
- I thought we were dating but we weren't.
- We met through work.
- I was the only one in
the whole entire play
that knew he was actually gay.
Like, he wasn't out yet.
- Cockapoo, cause that's what my dog is.
- I put Hannah dog.
- A Hannah dog...
- That's what that is.
- And I said my dog Hannah.
- [Morgan] Hannah!
- I didn't even know
(buzzer sound)
you had a dog.
- Wrong.
- What?
- A Scotty? A miniature schnauzer.
- Ew.
- But you gave away
the miniature schnauzer
that you had.
- Wheadon terrior
(yells)
- [Dan] I siad non-shedding
terrier, English?
- My mom!
- Parents.
(laughs)
- Oh yeah!
- [Kelsey] What, wait?
- [Bryan] Yeah!
(laughs)
- Fancy is my mom.
- Oh!
- I got it!
- I put me.
(laughs)
That's so awkward.
- Bette Midler?
- That's what I was gonna put.
- Oh I would do him.
- Who the hell is Matt Bomer?
- J-Law.
- Ok, I respect that.
- Dude, I was...
- Ok, I'm not even kidding,
ScarJo was up there.
- Miles Teller!
- Toby MacGuire.
- What?
(laughs)
- I said making people laugh.
- Aw, I put joy.
- I wrote funny.
- Listening.
(laughs)
- I put jokes.
- I put legs.
- I said I see the good in
everything and everyone.
- I said you care abut everyone else.
- He has a big heart.
- I thought you were gonna
write, "He has a big dick."
- Cream.
- Cream! I slap cream on.
- [Man] Boom!
Instead of just like applying
moisturize like this,
- Yep, yep.
- She fills it in her hands, handfuls,
and goes like this.
- [Gaby] Yep!
- I like always do my
hair or I wear a hat.
- [Morgan] Boom and boom.
Hair, hair and hair.
- I should've got hair!
- Always fixing your hair.
- Ok, also that's very true.
I get on Justin all
the time cause he walks
in late every day.
(laughs)
- I cross my fingers cause
when somebody's talking I don't want
to interrupt them.
- Yeah, so you go like this.
- [Man] So I cross my fingers
- [Woman] So you remember
what you're sasying.
That's your ritual.
- [Bryan] It is.
- Being late!
- What'd you write?
- [Dan] Lying or not going to bed by 10pm.
- Oh I wrote shoes in
the house or on stuff.
- I said people who are fake.
I just hate when we're like...
- Oh, loud people.
- Loud people.
- And then people chewing
with their mouth open.
- Yeah those are both true.
- [Morgan] He hates that.
(laughs)
- Somebody who's over...
- Oh cocky!
- Yeah.
- Got it!
- Cocky people?
- I can't stand that.
I actually can't stand...
- Cocky people are mean.
- I didn't know that.
- Are you kidding me?
Half of our fights are
because you're late.
- I'm the most confident person I know.
- I know and I see through it.
- I'm glad that the games was so close.
- [Gabby] Yeah.
- Between Gabby and I.
That way I don't feel
like a terrible boyfriend
and Gabby doesn't have to
feel like a bad friend.
- Yeah.
- We just both kind of average.
(laughs)
acquaintances of Alex's.
- I'm taking back our BFF necklaces.
(laughs)
- I feel so much love right now.
I got my crew right here.
Aw, here's your thumbnail.
- Aw.
- This is bullshit.
- You can't be embarrassed.
- I stll don't think this is right.
I still know you better,
what's his favorite ice cream?
Wrong, it's frozen yogurt.
(laughs)